hello i'm dilaura di kim
and i'll be talking about my research
project that i conducted with the
omixlogic research fellowship program at
pine biotech
my project was on how radiation is a
threat to humans and space and how this
correlated with the gut brain axis since
they're both hot topics of the century
i'll be discussing why studying the
effects of radiation on the human body
is important then i will explore the
subject
through my own research and findings and
finally link these results
to suggest feasible solutions when the
space inhabitant age of space travel
began two decades ago it brought on a
surge of possibilities in space research
as you can see from the figure several
international space patients conduct
research in various fields
to be able to continue these studies in
outer space the health and well-being of
astro scientists
are of great importance the unusual
conditions present in space stations due
to
increased radiation and microgravity can
cause a myriad of diseases
one of the most prominent conditions
observed in astronauts
who returned to earth after long
durations of space travel
was anxiety and depression
my focus will specifically be on high
lep ionizing radiation
because ionizing radiation causes a
greater threat to human health
than non-ionized radiation since it
carries higher energy
that can cause chemical reactions
whereas it does symmetry for radiation
that can be correlated with biological
effects is lep which is linear energy
transfer
high lead radiation poses a threat
because large structures can easily be
shielded from this type of radiation but
microscopic structures that are either
microbes or human cells cannot
here are some symptoms that are under
study to be controlled or improved upon
by nasa
they have a plan spending the next 10
years on how several implications
experienced in space will be overcome if
research continues at the current speed
radiation exposure is largely
uncontrolled and according to this
scheme it will continue to be
uncontrolled for much longer
given that the dose of radiation
exposure on the iss for six months is
almost 10 times greater than the
abdominal cc scan
there's more than enough reason to worry
to be worried about
its effects on the human body nowadays
research suggests that there's a strong
correlation between microbiome and
psychological health
therefore i suggest that the physical
limitations of space
that have an effect on our psychology
can be overcome by cultivating the
physiological effects of microbes
the course of action i followed to
analyze the effects of radiation on the
mosfet messy genome
subjected to high led ionizing radiation
is as follows
i first obtained the dataset that had 80
samples
categorized in four dosages 0.1.25 and
1gy
and the samples were collected 10 days
and 30 days post radiation
i then use the data 2 pipeline to obtain
abundances of bacteria
present in the sample the complete
dataset was then explored using the
output from the phylloc pipeline
i checked pca and nmds to see the
separation between groups
then i used the shannon index to further
explore the changes in biodiversity
next i checked that different dosages
and days were significantly different
between
groups as observed my aim was to confirm
if the effects of radiation persist even
after exposure is over and if low
dosages
have a greater impact as the
characteristics of ionizing radiation
suggest my first analysis was non-metric
multi-dimensional scaling which is an
iterative algorithm that helps us
visualize the multi-dimensional data in
a two-dimensional state
the data suggests post radiation could
be explored further since they are
grouped more separately
relative to 30 days
next the shannon index was calculated
the shonen index is proportional to the
effects
of number of species in the group which
means that we can reduce the species
richness and evenness using this value
as we can see from this comparison of
all the categories
the index is lower 4.1 and 0.25 gui
therefore moving forward we will focus
on these two groups
and here is an output from the final
seek pipeline where we can observe the
relations between significantly abundant
otu
otu 4 and 5 are related because they're
both in the back of the bacterium family
which is an important
point to keep in mind for the rest of
the research
it can also be observed that for 0.1 and
0.25 gy
at 10 days there is lower abundance
compared to the others
to check if this observable difference
is
significant i followed this with some
statistical tests
in accordance with my previous results i
decided to test 0.1 and 0.25 gy
and compare it to 0gy as my control
i conducted anova and the results
indicated that
in general there was a significant
difference between the three dosages but
not safe
and that there was no interaction
between days and those two to test
further which those which had the most
significant effect i then conducted t
test
and the results displayed a strong trend
in 0.1 gy at 10 days post radiation
being the significant group
i then selected operational taxonomic
units that passed the piece
0.05 threshold and profiled them
my interest was focused on otu 3 4 5
and 8 as you can see from this figure
i also compared the abundances of
different families of bacteria that were
present in
two groups and you can observe a
decrease in erythropoietin
bacteria lactobacillus bacteria and
bifida bacteria
there's also an increase in
varicomicrobia
the results from this graph that align
with my previous findings
from the statistical analysis are
lactobacillus and by
the bacterium they are also associated
with metabolites that have an effect on
the nervous system through the gut brain
axis
the vagus nerve and the enterodendritic
nerve play an important role in this
association connecting the components of
the gut and the
brain and the famous saying your gut is
your second brain
the species corresponding to the ot use
that for significant are
bipolar bacterium pastorius by the
bacterium longum
lactobacillus choline and lactobacillus
causers
they're commonly found in the human gut
too
they're associated with the production
of gaba gamma aminobutyric acid which is
the chief inhibitory trans
neurotransmitter in the central nervous
system
it plays a crucial role in depression
and anxiety
when produced in low levels since these
bacteria have protein choline genes in
the glutamines and glutamine synthase
pathways
we can assume that kava decreases
proportionately to the decrease in the
abundance of these species
since exogenous kava does not have an
effect on the central nervous system
the most efficient method of increasing
gaba is through stimulating its
production by supplying patients with
probiotics
rich and lactobacillus and bipod
bacteria
in conclusion we can sum up these
findings by saying that lower doses of
high let ionizing radiation
has a greater impact on the gut by the
bacterium lactobacillus abundances
more specifically 0.1 gy
the acclimatization period can be
deduced as 10 days
since 30 days post radiation did not
pass a significant threshold
however this rehabilitation period could
be dependent on the length of exposure
the mice in the study were not subjected
to exposure lengths as long as
astronauts on the iss
further studies can include longer
exposure lengths and synergetic effects
of radiation and microgravity
however this was an important precursor
study on how probiotics can be used
in treatment of psychological diseases
and to overcome the effects of radiation
and here are some of the limitations
that i came across while conducting this
research
one of them was optimizing parameters
for the pipeline
the other one was the sample size and
dosages because they were limited
there were only 10 samples for each
category
and there were no dosages for radiation
in between
0.1 and 0.25 and one dose gui
as for the taxonomic profiling for the
16s regions bacteria have very similar
sequences when they're in the same genus
so it was difficult to differentiate
them and the last limitation was that
this study was conducted on mice
which means that we can only make
assumptions on how these mechanisms
truly work in humans
here are my references
i would like to thank the omixlogic
fellowship team for their continuous
support
i had minimal bioinformatics background
before starting this internship and
throughout the three months i acquired
knowledge on various bioinformatics
techniques
from transcriptomics and genomics to
epigenetics and metagenomics
i was able to design and conduct a
project with the guidance of my
supervisors
who supplied me with invaluable feedback
i was very happy
to be part of the scientific community
thank you